mais d'abord mais d'abord le match
retour Macron Le Pen 5 ans après les
temps forts les phrases à retenir avec
Flora sauvage
pendant près de trois heures ce sont
deux mercredi soir le président sortant
a commencé en attaquant sa rivale sur sa
promesse d'augmenter de 10 % les
salaires si elle était élu vous n'allez
pas faire les salaires Madame Le Pen et
vous ne ferez pas non plus à déprime
monsieur
je ne le dis pas voilà je dis j'enlève
les charges du côté employeur j'enlève
les impôts mais vous essayez de faire
croire que vous vous allez augmenter les
salaires de 10% et que ce sera récurrent
je dis juste non c'est pas vrai il y a
des employeurs qui le font d'autres non
sur l'environnement Marine Le Pen
critique Emmanuel Macron sur sa vision
d'une écologie punitive celui-ci dénonce
le programme de Marine Le Pen qui veut
selon le BIS subventionner les
hydrocarbures vous êtes
climato-sceptique je suis absolument pas
que climato-sceptique
en aucun cas mais vous vous êtes un peu
climatohypocrite sur le voile Marine Le
Pen passe à l'offensive en rappelant
l'une de ses promesses phares il faut
faire reculer les islamistes et pour
cela je le crois il faut interdire le
voile dans l'espace public
la laïcité ça n'est pas à combattre une
religion et donc avec moi il y aura pas
l'interdiction ni du foulard ni de la
kippa ni de quelques signes religieux
dans l'espace public mais c'est sur la
politique internationale que les deux
rivaux se sont écharpés avec la charge
d'Emmanuel Macron contre Marine Le Pen
sur ses liens avec Vladimir Poutine du
pouvoir russe et que vous dépendez de
Monsieur Poutine vous avez contracté un
prêt en 2015 auprès d'une banque russe
et donc vous ne parlez pas à d'autres
dirigeants vous parlez à votre banquier
quand vous parlez de la Russie devant
ses accusations Marine Le Pen réplique
qu'elle est une femme libre si le
président s'est montré à l'offensive la
candidate du RN a défendu ses positions
lors de ce débat qui a été suivi par 15
millions et demi de téléspectateurs la
pire audience de l'histoire lors d'un
débat télévisé de l'entre-deux tours
que l'on va analyser avec mes invités
Catherine tricot bonsoir bienvenue
Catherine vous êtes directrice de la
revue regard votre le dernier numéro
consacré à la Une Jean-Luc Mélenchon la
gauche c'est lui Frédéric potier bonsoir
vous êtes essayiste expert et social à
la Fondation Jean Jaurès et vous publiez
pierre malins France la foi démocratique
c'est aux éditions bouquin j'accueille
également Pierre Latry bonsoir mais
bonsoir chef de groupe chez
Ipsos notre partenaire des soirées
électorales et on se retrouvera donc
dimanche puisque nous avons une soirée
spéciale LCP Public Sénat à partir de
19h30 soyez là Laetitia cruppa bonsoir
Laetitia dans les listes politiques Euro
2 de vous retrouver bon Catherine tricot
vous y échappez pas la question rituel
qui a gagné hier soir chacun a conforté
son son camp à mon avis et ceux qui ne
veut qu'ils veulent aller voter Emmanuel
Macron sans conviction éviter de
l'écouter à mon avis ça explique une
partie de cette faible audience moi j'ai
autour de moi et j'ai beaucoup entendu
sur les réseaux
si on veut voter Macron faut mieux ne
pas l'écouter donc je pense que chacun a
conforté son son image elle
d'une candidate proche des
préoccupations populaires et une façon
de s'exprimer assez simple et efficace
tandis que lui il a plutôt conforté
l'idée d'une une candidature plutôt
contemporaine pro-européenne liées
aux transformations de la société
d'aujourd'hui avec le métissage
l'économie numérique etc l'écologie donc
je pense que chacun a développé son je
pense pas que ça avait fait bouger les
lignes on verra les sondages quand ils
vont tomber mais moi je dirais que c'est
ballot sens alors moi la réflexion que
que je me fais c'est presque un débat à
front renversé d'une certaine façon
au-delà du jeu de mots un email Macron
plus offensif attaquant Marine Le Pen
sur son bilan de député alors qu'on
attendait une Marine Le Pen attaquant
Emmanuel Macron sur son bilan à l'Elysée
et puis une candidatérienne donnant
cette image apaisée qu'elle essaie
d'imposer depuis des mois on était
évidemment très loin de l'agressivité de
2017 est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
cette idée fédéricotier un débat affront
renversé oui on a vu un président de la
République candidat Emmanuel Macron très
offensif et on a vu une Marine Le Pen
essayant de camper une posture
présidentielle crédit pour contraster
avec le débat d'il y a 5 ans je pense
qu'effectivement chaque électorat aura
vu dans chacun des candidats dans
chacune des prestations des raisons de
voter ou pas moi j'ai l'impression quand
même que le Président de la République a
bien défendu son bilan tandis que Marine
Le Pen a mal défendu son programme et je
crois que sur toute la première partie
sur l'économie on a vu un président qui
attaqué beaucoup et une candidate tu
rassemblant national qui était beaucoup
sur la défensive et qui avait du mal
quand même aller au bout de ses
raisonnements on a beaucoup parlé
d'arrogance avant ça fait partie des
arguments donnés par les soutiens de
Marine Le Pen après est-ce que vous
l'avez trouvé arrogant
je l'ai trouvé professoral alors est-ce
qu'un professeur est forcément arrogant
ça c'est voilà chacun chacun jugera je
l'ai trouvé oui c'est à dire que si on
analyse uniquement la posture et le
positionnement c'est vrai que il était
c'est vraiment
stylistiquement elle était il était un
poil au-dessus quoi toujours cette
posture un peu jupiterienne à lui faire
la leçon à l'attaquer pour éviter me
semble-t-il d'avoir justement à faire
son bilan moi il me semble qu'il n'a
fait absolument aucun bilan de son
quinquennat et qu'il a évité toutes les
flèches qu'elle pouvait lui envoyer et
qui était nombreuses elles sont
nombreuses les flèches qu'on peut
envoyer à Emmanuel Macron donc si vous
voulez oui comme il a tout de suite pris
le lead sur l'attaque et je trouve oui
que dans la posture il était il était un
peu dans le mépris alors les Français
ont-ils trouvé Emmanuel Macron plus
convaincant ou Marine Le Pen on a un
sondage qui nous éclaire pour réaliser
par l'institut est là pour BFM TV
59% des personnes interrogées ont pouvez
Emmanuel Macron le président sortant
plus convaincant pour 39% à Marine Le
Pen pierre Latry je sais que vous allez
avoir des résultats mais vous pouvez pas
encore nous les donner vous avez vous
aussi sonder les Français à l'issue de
de ce débat et est-ce que ce débat peut
un même un petit peu à la marge avoir
fait bouger les lignes
il peut faire bouger les lignes un petit
peu à la marge effectivement mais je ne
pense pas qu'il aura une influence
énorme finalement sur le sur les
intentions de vote comme on l'a dit ils
ont été tous les deux un petit peu dans
leur rôle respectif Marine Le Pen s'est
affiché comme une candidate proche des
gens Emmanuel Macron comme un candidat
sérieux avec les épaules de président
qui maîtrisent très bien ces dossiers ça
a été un débat très technocratique donc
comme ils sont restés un petit peu tous
les deux dans leur rôle je ne pense pas
que ça aura une énorme influence mais ce
qui est certain c'est qu'Emmanuel Macron
étant le favori qui était en avance dans
les intentions de vote si le débat n'a
pas beaucoup d'impact sur les intentions
de vote c'est plutôt à sa faveur oui
mais c'est ce que je vais vous dire
Catherine tricot est-ce qu'il y a pas
quand même une petite erreur stratégique
de Marine Le Pen on a bien compris sa
cohérence sa logique de de normalisation
mais il fallait aussi qu'elle prenne
peut-être un peu plus de risques qu'elle
soit plus offensive pour rattraper le
retard que les sondages lui promettent
soyons prudent comme toujours oui mais
je pense que quand même le plus gros
retard qu'elle avait c'était sa
banalisation là elle est rentrée dans le
rang des hommes et des femmes politiques
comme les autres et je pense que de ce
point de vue hier c'est un gros succès
pour elle parce qu'elle a elle a semblé
à l'égal
on peut discuter qui a gagné peu ou pro
mais voilà elle est potentiellement
comme et d'ailleurs Emmanuel Macron l'a
traité de cette manière c'est-à-dire que
vous avez raison de dire qu'il était un
peu professoral mais jamais par exemple
il lui a dit vous êtes d'extrême droite
Madame Le Pen vous avez raison etc enfin
bon c'était moi je pense qu'il y a des
rentrée dans le dans le c'est marrant
l'égalité
d'extrême droite qui est factuellement
correct de Marine Le Pen de Pierre
je voudrais avoir Pascal Perrine en face
de moi parce que je peux vous le
démontrer point par point c'est un c'est
un programme et une candidature et un
héritage d'extrême droite donc en tout
point elle est d'extrême droite et c'est
drôle comme cette critique devient même
entre nous
passe finalement dans le débat public
c'est juste qualification c'est pas une
critique de dire aux États d'extrême
droite finalement c'est c'est toute
l'offensive rhétorique Le Pen voilà qui
depuis 15 ans nous dit à chaque fois
quand vous dites d'extrême droite vous
m'insultez ah bon maintenant c'est un
positionnement politique et maintenant
il est inscrit même dans nos débats
c'est un peu effrayant mais
on parlait de la de la banalisation moi
je trouve qu'il y a un moment et je suis
sûr que vous allez me suivre en régie un
moment du débat qui qui peut sembler
anecdotique mais qui d'une certaine
façon
prouve cette banalisation c'est ce
moment où la tension a laissé la place à
quelques discrets souris regardez
je crois que c'est factuel je serai très
respectueux à votre égard vous ça ne se
voit pas moi j'ai peur que ça se voit
beaucoup madame voilà c'était un moment
un peu un peu particulier non
en fait moi j'ai souffert pendant 5 ans
j'ai porté la nation donc moi ça se voit
sur moi vous en 5 ans ça n'a pas laissé
beaucoup enfin le temps n'a pas laissé
beaucoup de tracé il y a un côté à la
fois
de sympathie entre les deux qu'on ne
supposait pas possible dans un débat
comme celui-là surtout à l'aune de ce
qui s'était passé il y a 5 jours
et puis un deuxième côté qui est quand
même moins sympathique que tu n'en avait
on pourrait partir parler d'une
mithridatisation de l'opinion
pierre-latri sur cette idée d'extrême
droite on finit par
trouver ça ben voilà Marine Le Pen au
second tour pour la deuxième fois
consécutive un débat où elle fait bon
plus ou moins je vegan en tout cas voilà
elle est présent et c'est pas
catastrophique au fur et à mesure on
s'habitue à voir son parti et la famille
Le Pen au second tour d'une élection
présidentielle en France ça peut
paraître assez étonnant si on regarde un
petit peu en arrière en 2002 il y avait
pas eu de débats il y avait eu un refus
de débattre en 2017 le débat avec quand
même été beaucoup plus agressif là le
joint j'ai trouvé ça très courtois au
final et on a vraiment le sentiment
maintenant qui a effectivement une
tripartisation qui s'installe et que le
RN est le RN et le bloc on va dire
autour du RN est en train de devenir
finalement quelque chose d'assez normal
dans la vie politique et ça ne suscite
plus forcément les réactions que ça
suscité en 2002 c'était il y a seulement
20 ans donc voilà il y avait vraiment
une opposition très forte est-ce que ce
débat apaisé c'était le cas hier vous y
voyez aussi un progrès une certaine
façon si on compare celui-ci et celui
d'y a 5 ans alors moi j'y vois un
progrès par rapport à 5 ans mais j'y
vois aussi un progrès par rapport au
début de la campagne on a quand même
commencé une campagne présidentielle
avec Éric Zemmour en septembre qui
toutes les semaines tous les trois jours
sortaient des énormes unités sur pétains
sur les enfants handicapés sur je ne
sais quoi encore et donc le fait de
pouvoir montrer qu'au fond la démocratie
c'est pas la guerre civile moi je trouve
ça effectivement très positif
n’empêche il y a eu quand même un duel à
fleurer moucheté c'est à dire qu'il y a
eu un exercice d'humanisation chez l'un
et chez l'autre et il y a eu des
échanges aussi très vif et de courtoises
courtois effectivement mais franc et
j'allais presque dire viril sur la
Russie sur la laïcité sur les questions
juridiques sur l'Europe je crois que les
deux personnalités ne sont pas fait de
cadeaux mais juste juste pour rajouter
Emmanuel Macron a participé à cette
normalisation de l'extrême droite depuis
le début de son quinquennat il parle à
valeur actuelle il téléphone Eric
Zemmour quand il se fait agresser dans
la rue Emmanuel Macron joue un jeu
dangereux depuis le début de son arrivée
est au second tour d'une présidentielle
il peut pas président élu faire comme si
il y avait pas tant de Français qui
aussi assez français là qui s'adresse on
peut pas faire comme si il y avait pas x
millions de Français
depuis le début il veut se duel c'est de
la stratégie aussi évidemment stratégie
de la stratégie avec Marine Le Pen il
faut s'adresser à cette électorale et
pas faire comme si c'était un électorat
qu'on soit congomme soit qu'on comprend
avec des pincettes tout à fait d'accord
avec vous sans vouloir revenir toujours
à 2002 à l'époque l'extrême droite peser
20% là on est plutôt si on cumule
Nicolas Dupont-Aignan Éric Zemmour
Marine Le Pen autour d'un tiers des
électeurs donc c'est un point maintenant
qui est évidemment juste oublié que ce
qu'il fallait séduire hier soir c'était
le public de gauche on va y revenir
je voudrais parler un peu de la de la
forme de ce débat je rappelle l'audience
un 15 600000 téléspectateurs c'est près
d'un million de moins qu'il y a 5 ans
c'était déjà le plus mauvais score il y
a 5 ans et donc c'est le pire score de
l'histoire des débats présidentiels et
vous posez la question Laetitia d'un
d'un changement de format c'est quoi
votre écoutez quand je regarde le débat
d'hier je me dis qu'on s'est vraiment
americanisé mais tous c'est à dire pas
uniquement à la France toutes les
démocraties finalement même pas que
occidentale parce qu'en Tunisie en 2019
c'était exactement le même format qui
avait été repris celui américain
c'est-à-dire que de journalistes
modérateurs on sait plus comment les
appeler et des candidats qui se font
face avec un chapitrage très serré avec
un rythme enfin c'est vraiment le format
américain quoique là pour le dernier
débat Biden Trump et bien mais une
unique journaliste vous voyez donc il y
a quand même une petite variation un
petit changement mais c'est vrai qu'on
est tous sur le même modèle qu'est-ce
qui va pas pour vous dans ce système
dans ce modèle un peu tout en fait le
saucissonnage des thermes pardon pour
pour ce mot mais il a il a au moins le
mérite d'être clair
mais enfin ça donnait cette impression
là c'est à dire que en fait ça donne une
impression de rythme et de succession
d'empilement finalement de sujets qui
sont pourtant fondamentaux et on a du
mal à saisir le projet et le projet de
chacun la vision la vision de la société
or une élection présidentielle ce n'est
pas un quiz une élection présidentielle
c'est un destin commun que l'on essaye
de construire ensemble donc il y a aussi
ces journalistes alors ils sont deux on
se demande à quoi il servent ils servent
bien sûr à minuter il servent aussi à
chapitrer justement à passer les plats
mais bon pourquoi des journalistes pour
donner une idée ou une impression de
profondeur de sérieux de garantie pour
ce débat mais honnêtement on pourrait
s'en passer moi je ferai carrément les
deux sans personnes vous voyez une sorte
de vraie arène ce serait un peu
compliqué pour changer le thème parce
que qui déciderait de de passer de
l'éducation à l'écologie bref et on sait
que en plus les candidats et leurs
équipes un pouce ses règles ou en tout
cas sont très très présentes pour les
négociers et c'est peut-être là tout le
problème Thomas et c'est peut-être même
l'allégorie du journaliste aujourd'hui
Pourquoi
ma part le politique et non pas par le
professionnel qui connaît quand même je
crois son métier quand on voit la
polémique qui est entourée vous savez
les plans de coupe alors qu'on dit des
plantes d'écoute avec le réalisateur qui
était complètement pressurisé parce
qu'il faut pas trop en faire ni rien ni
quand il se gratte le nez ni quand il
est fish enfin et on sait que dans le
cas régie le réalisateur est entouré
mais physiquement des deux réalisateurs
conseils de chaque candidat qui à chaque
fois qu'il appuie sur un bouton peu
potentiellement lui dire quelque chose
enfin on se demande si ce débat
présidentiel n'est pas tout simplement
un pur exercice de communication
politique c'est aussi un rendez-vous
démocratique important donc on est c'est
compliqué je suis assez d'accord je
pense qu'il faut en changer la force il
y a un autre élément que je trouve
vraiment intéressant dans dans votre
réflexion c'est le manque de vision
alors je sais pas si c'est la forme du
débat qui ne l'empêche mais moi c'était
une frustration d'hier soir est-ce que
vous l'avez ressenti vous aussi oui
exactement moi j'ai été frappé par
l'absence de de projection à moyen terme
sur une vision de la France à 10 ans à
20 ans Emmanuel Macron a parlé un peu de
son plan France 2030 mais ça c'est resté
sur
sur un aspect très marginal au fond on a
attendu quand même une vision qui est
pas venue parce qu'on était beaucoup
projet contre bilan bilan contre projet
et au fond on n'a pas senti ni chez l'un
ni chez l'autre une volonté de se
projeter dans la génération d'après et
ça je pense qu'on peut le regretter et
effectivement je pense que la forme du
débat joue beaucoup vous le regrettez
aussi Catherine tricot parce que je suis
pas tout à fait sentie ça c'est à dire
comment sur la forme ou sur le manque de
vision sur le caractère politique c'est
à dire qu'en fait ce que je pense c'est
qu'ils se sont un peu débattus l'un et
l'autre pour essayer quand même malgré
ce chapitrage pour essayer de
réintroduire du sens et du fond et je
pense que Marine Le Pen particulièrement
a essayé de faire cela d'ailleurs elle
est apparue comme assez faible sur les
éléments techniques de dossier par
contre je n'ai trouvé pas mauvaise moi
sur le
le caractère politique de son discours
elle était approximative sur les
dossiers mais bien campé sur les
orientations moi je note par exemple sur
le sur l'écologie elle sait pas laisser
strictement enfermée dans le débat pour
ou contre les éoliennes elle a commencé
en disant le problème de du
réchauffement climatique c'est la
mondialisation on y reviendra ça parce
que c'est un extrait qui vous a qui vous
a frappé parce que elle a réussi à
donner du sens global à ce moment-là
dans un instant à une question pierre à
la triste sur cette faible audience
est-ce que ça laisse prévoir une forte
abstention dimanche
elle s'explique parce que il y a quand
même deux éléments qui font pas oublier
qui sont très importants qui ont
commencé déjà en 2017 mais qui se sont
poursuivis c'est qu'on a déjà une
tripartisation de la vie politique et
donc c'est à dire qu'il n'y a plus de
blocs mais trois et donc forcément là un
des blocs était absent du débat donc ça
peut créer de la frustration et l'envie
de ne pas regarder parce que bon
finalement on ne se sent pas tellement
concernés on peut rajouter le quatrième
bloc c'est à dire les abstentions
évidemment les abstentionnistes qui déjà
ont tendance en plus à moins regarder et
ensuite l'autre chose qui est quand même
importante c'est que c'est un duel que
les Français n'attendaient pas vraiment
n'avaient pas vraiment envie de revoir
sont deux candidats qui sont pas très
appréciés alors les autres je n'ai pas
que les autres l'été mais eux en tout
cas ne le sont pas il y a énormément de
critiques qui sont formulés à leur
endroit donc finalement ce ne sont pas
de candidats qui créent énormément
d'envie chez les Français donc je pense
que ça explique aussi pourquoi on a une
limite aussi sur l'abstention qu'est-ce
que c'est quoi les chiffres qui qui
ressortent là pour les abstentionnistes
ont été plus nombreux à ne pas à ne pas
regarder le débat oui oui ça
l'abstention qui pourrait plutôt
desservir Marine Le Pen si elle se
confirme dimanche ricotier moi je pense
que dans une démocratie jusqu'au dernier
jour tout compte et tout des bas contes
et chaque voix compte mais oui à
l'évidence je pense que Marine Le Pen
doit engranger des votes positifs là où
Emmanuel Macron a quand même
techniquement un peu d'avance donc je
pense aussi le fait de ne pas avoir de
de de sondage extrêmement serré entre
les deux a peut-être joué aussi sur
l'audience de ce débat avec un petit
bémol quand même sur les électeurs de la
France insoumise qui sont les plus
nombreux si décident de s'abstenir ça
sera plutôt à mauvais pour Emmanuel
Macron pour l'instant on a plutôt quoi
40% selon les instituts qui des
électeurs de Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui
disent qu'ils voteraient Emmanuel Macron
on va parler jeter un coup d'oeil à la
perception avec Marion vigros de ce
débat dans la presse européenne bonsoir
Marion et donc vous avez lu la presse de
chez nos voisins pour nous certains
avaient prédit un débat au goût de
tisane il n'en a rien été voici
l'analyse du quotidien belge Le Soir qui
évoque un débat à couteau tirer et un
président à l'offensive qui a souvent
mouché son adversaire globalement tous
les journaux étrangers en conviennent
avantages au président sortant dans ce
débat voile rouble retraite Macron
remporte le défi avec Le Pen titre la
Stompa le journal italien qui s'étonne
justement du manque d'offensive de
Marine Le Pen qui restait je cite
indécise et qui n'a pas convaincu
laissant une grande partie de
l'initiative à Emmanuel Macron Emmanuel
Macron qui avait tout à perdre ou à
gagner et rappelle le quotidien The
Guardian qui souligne les arguments
solides du candidat ça sérénité son
expérience même face à une Marine Le Pen
très faible sur les questions techniques
et mise en difficulté sur ses relations
avec le pouvoir russe néanmoins le
journal britannique estime que la
candidate du rassemblement national
était mieux préparée qu'en 2017
endossant enfin les habits de mer de la
nation d'ailleurs l'attitude des
candidats aussi étaient scrutés par la
presse étrangère le journal El païs
constate que Marine Le Pen a adouci son
image qu'elle apparaissait même plus
bronzés quand le journal italien le
Coria della Serra évoque à l'incapacité
pour Emmanuel Macron d'effacer
totalement cette image de jeune homme
arrogant impatient dans son fauteuil et
en Allemagne en Allemagne le ton est
plus inquiet du début à la fin Marine Le
Pen a montré son vrai visage titre
l'hebdomadaire allemande qui constate
que la candidate déambule à la
télévision comme si sa politique
d'extrême droite était un projet comme
un autre le journal de Francfort
Frankfort alguemineux s'attarde lui
longuement sur le ressentiment
entièrement de la candidate Le Pen elle
qui a concentré ses premières attaques
sur l'Allemagne dont elle ne veut plus
soutenir je cite les erreurs
idéologiques en matière de politique
énergétique alors qu'à l'opposé le
candidat Macron a rappelé son
attachement au couple franco-allemand
est justement le journal économique
américain le Wall Street Journal signal
souligne le contraste entre les deux
programmes avec un débat qui illustre à
quel point la France est devenue un pays
profondément divisé sur son identité
nationale et sa place dans le monde la
conclusion revient au quotidien suisse
Le Temps je le cite ni vainqueur ni
vaincu pas de dérapage rien de nouveau
par rapport aux engagements de campagne
de France et au milieu
vieux gouffre qui séparent de projets
impossible à réconcilier merci Marion
les Francis réconciliables ce sera l'un
des thèmes de notre second débat tout à
l'heure autre élément autre information
de cette journée c'est cette tribune
publiée dans le monde les chefs de
gouvernement de trois pays européens
l'Allemagne l'Espagne est le Portugal
donc olapshols Pedro Sanchez et Antonio
Costa vous le voyez qui
mettent en garde sur les risques d'une
victoire de Marine Le Pen et appelle ta
beauté pour le candidat démocratique ne
sites ni Marine Le Pen ni Emmanuel
Macron dans cette tribune mais les
termes sont clairs c'est le choix entre
un candidat démocrate qui croit que la
France est plus forte dans une Union
européenne puissante et autonome et une
candidate d'extrême droite qui se range
ouvertement du côté de ceux qui
attaquent notre liberté et notre
démocratie c'était Catherine tricot
aussi l'un des enjeux du débat hier soir
est-ce que pour vous sur l'Europe
Emmanuel Macron a réussi son coup il
voulait quoi débusquer en fait la la
réalité du programme européen de Marine
Le Pen oui je crois de ce point de vue
dans
les termes du débat je pense que Marine
Le Pen est une candidate xénophobe et
que c'est une candidate qui nationaliste
et qui est absolument d'ailleurs elle
l'a bien dit elle est contre l'Union
européenne elle est pour l'Europe des
nations et elle est elle reconnaît
chacun le droit d'être nationaliste et
elle elle est pour nous tous donc je
crois qu'il a réussi à le mettre en
évidence à plusieurs moments cette la
caractérisation de son projet comme
xénophobe nationaliste populiste et
raciste et à mon avis sur plusieurs
thèmes ça c'est vu et ça s'est vu
notamment sur la question européenne
pierre latrie une tribune comme celle-là
est-ce que ça ça peut peser même un tout
petit peu sur une partie de l'opinion
française c'était dans le dans le match
de crédibilité ou de présidentialité de
de luné de l'autre vous voyez ce que je
veux dire je pense pas que ça pas du
tout
les électeurs d'Emmanuel Macron que ils
vont faire le bon choix peut-être mais
je pense que ça n'aura pas de d'impact
sur des sur les abstentionnistes vous
mentez sur la marchandise c'est la
formule qui est utilisée par le
président sortant pour caractériser
Marine Le Pen à propos de l'Europe
écouter
valeur de l'Europe et des règles du
Conseil de l'Europe jusqu'au marché de
l'énergie dont vous proposez de sortir
jusqu'à Schengen sur laquelle vous
n'êtes pas clair votre projet quand on
remet bric-à-brique les choses en place
c'est un projet qui ne dit pas son nom
mais qui consiste à faire sortir de
l'Europe des nations oui enfin si c'est
plus l'Union européenne vous sortez de
l'Union européenne même Le Pen ah non
mais pardon de vous le dire on peut on
peut décider de ripoliner tout seul la
façade mais enfin c'est pas c'est une
copropriété aucun moment donné dans une
copropriété vous pouvez pas dire du jour
au lendemain ça s'appelle plus la
copropriété ça s'appelle comme j'ai
décidé parce que je m'appelle Madame Le
Pen et bien j'ai beaucoup plus
d'ambition que vous mais Madame Le Pen
moi j'ai une ambition je la porte je le
fais dans le respect des autres et j'ai
fait avancer les choses mais je ne mens
pas sur la marchan
vous montez sur la marchand Frédéric
potier l'Europe c'est on le savait vrai
ligne de fracture entre les programmes
de Marine Le Pen et d'Emmanuel Macron
entre leurs électorats aussi finalement
Emmanuel Macron il est dans une vraie
cohérence quand il parle de ça moi c'est
le sentiment que que j'ai eu alors
est-ce que c'est aussi le cas de Marine
Le Pen alors email le con manuel le
Macron est dans une vraie cohérence
parce qu'il est pro européen et
d'ailleurs il est allé faire campagne
dans l'entre-deux-tours ou des zones
historiquement très pro européenne la
Bretagne Strasbourg il assume cette
construction commune de l'Europe avec
cette image qui est comment je trouve
bien trouver de la copropriété et je
trouve qu'il a réussi à bien débusquer
ce qui n'allait pas dans le programme de
main Le Pen qui est de dire finalement
je veux une Europe à la carte je garde
une certaine politique mais je j'en
choisis pas une autre et c'est là où on
a vu une candidate quand même très très
mal à l'aise certes elle a assigné un
certain nombre de choses elle a assigné
des concepts l'Europe des nations sans
parce que je trouve qu'il y a un non
respect de l'électorat de Marine Le Pen
par la candidat du Rassemblement
national Catherine tricot alors on l'a
vu dans le dans le sujet de Flora
sauvage tout à l'heure cette échange
entre Emmanuel Macron et Marine Le Pen
sur à propos de l'écologie vous êtes
climato-sceptique et elle lui répond un
peu un peu après quelques minutes plus
tard vous êtes climato hypocrite c'est
un moment fort que vous avez retenu mais
peut-être plus que au-delà de ça la
charge de Marine Le Pen contre la
mondialisation le libre-échange
la lignée de ce qu'on vient de se dire
c'est à dire qu'en fait moi je ce que je
note c'est qu'elle réussit quand même à
se désenclaver de simples thèmes de la
sécurité de l'immigration et la réussite
à incorporer dans son discours par
exemple la question de l'écologie sous
un angle vraiment
cohérent et d'extrême droite avec sa
vision c'est à dire elle dit je suis
contre la mondialisation et je suis
localiste et donc elle elle nous dit une
une réponse ce qu'elle dit n'est pas
complètement faux quand elle dit 50% de
nos de notre production de CO2 est liée
à nos échanges internationaux évidemment
si on faisait si on produisait en France
tout ce qu'on achète à l'étranger on
produirait quand même encore du CO2 donc
elle elle manipule un peu les idées
est-ce qu'elle elle utilise ce thème
pour dire on fait en France on fait
entre nous on se remet entre nous on
ferme les frontières et et elle elle
retourne un petit peu la question
écologique comme une question qui
devient
réactionnaire conservatrice et refermer
sur des quand même l'économie du
transport ces fameux dans le bilan dans
le bilan carbone
la critique moi je que j'ai trouvé c'est
que la critique de la mondialisation moi
ce qui m'a frappé c'est que quand elle
dit ça d'abord elle
ose dire que c'est une question
systémique donc elle dit bien que la
question d'écologie n'est pas qu'une
question technique du nombre d'éoliennes
donc elle élève quand même le débat et
je pense que ça aussi auprès de grand
nombre d'électeurs en faveur de
l'écologie que ce soit Yannick Jadot ou
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui contestent
aussi cette mondialisation qui fait
qu'on échange qu'on fabrique là puis là
puis là puis là enfin les chaînes de
valeur qui font que un produit un bilan
carbone catastrophique quoi alors
justement effectivement c'est ce qui est
intéressant pierre latrie sur le
l'électorat de Jean-Luc Mélenchon on en
a énormément parlé depuis le soir du du
premier tour et c'était un enjeu fort de
ce débat plus difficile le défi était
plus difficile pour Marine Le Pen que
pour Emmanuel Macron se rapprocher des
électeurs de Jean-Luc Mélenchon il y a
ce moment là il y a quoi le moment sur
les retraites où Marine Le Pen peut
s'adresser aux électeurs de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon oui bien sûr c'était sur cette
question là qu'elle était qu'elle était
attendue peut-être par les électeurs de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon parce que c'est une
réforme d'Emmanuel Macron qui a quand
même enfin qui fait beaucoup de bruit et
qui déplaît beaucoup dans l'électorat de
gauche mais je pense qu'elle n'a pas ici
hier vraiment à s'adresser à cet
électorat j'ai pas trouvé qu'elle avait
tellement tenté de le faire d'ailleurs
en soi et donc je pense que là dessus je
ne sais pas si elle a fait son deuil de
sélectoralam mais en tout cas elle n'a
pas n'a pas pour moi réussi à le faire
comment vous l'expliquez stratégiquement
parce que c'était trop compliqué de
s'adresser directement à cet électoral
là sans perdre son électorat classique
traditionnel c'est la difficulté pour
elle parce que Emmanuel Macron lui c'est
plus simple il mise sur le fond
républicain donc il dit voilà il faut
vous allez pas voter pour moi parce que
vous m'appréciez particulièrement mais
parce que en face de moi c'est l'extrême
droite pour Marine Le Pen c'est beaucoup
plus difficile parce que pour l'instant
le seul vrai report de voix qui est là
c'est celui d'Éric Zemmour elle ne peut
pas perdre non plus on a quand même 20%
des électeurs derrière du premier tour
qui n'iront pas voter pour elle au
second tour sur qui s'absiendront soit
qui voteront pour Emmanuel Macron donc
elle n'a pas une complet un report
complet et elle ne doit pas perdre non
plus cette base là donc c'est assez
difficile de jouer sur les deux tableaux
un autre extrait que vous avez choisi
Frédéric potier parmi les temps forts il
y a cet échange sur la laïcité quand le
en sortant dit à la candidate du
rassemblement national lui propose de
relire la Constitution
le principe d'égalité fait que si vous
rentrez dans cette logique Madame Le Pen
vous interdirez tous les signaux
religieux dans l'espace public et pas
simplement le foulard vous n'avez pas lu
ma loi non mais j'ai lu la Constitution
française vous m'excuserez de cela et
elle les
lois vous prendrez même si vous étiez
élu ce que je ne souhaite pas évidemment
elle devra respecter une constitution
bon et donc notre Constitution nos
textes fondamentaux c'est cela c'est la
laïcité la laïcité c'est un principe de
liberté et donc à l'école il n'y a pas
de voile parce qu'on forme des
consciences il y a aucun signe religieux
d'ailleurs
pourquoi vous souhaitiez revoir cette
séquence sur hypothécaire si vous frappe
alors j'ai trouvé que le Président de la
République s'afficher vraiment comme le
défenseur de l'État de droit le
défenseur des institutions alors même
que Marine Le Pen défendait une idée
pour le coup très d'extrême droite qui
était dire je vais interdire un signe
religieux mais je vais surtout interdire
le le voile et en faisant ça évidemment
et stigmatiser une certaine population
et là elle a pas du tout cherché du tout
chercher à attirer un électorat de
gauche à elle et j'ai trouvé que la
partie de ping-pong était plutôt réussi
parce que Emmanuel Macron a encore mis
le doigt sur la vraie difficulté de la
proposition de Marine Le Pen qui au fond
était de discriminer les Français selon
leur apparence
oui alors là aussi on a beaucoup parlé
de de la stratégie consistait à
débusquer ou à clarifier un certain
nombre de choses Catherine tricot on
sortait d'une semaine un peu flou sur
cette question du voile ou du foulard de
la part de Marine Le Pen oui je pensais
ce qu'on vient de dire elle ne peut pas
perdre son électorat donc là elle est
revenue sur sur des fondamentaux mais
moi je note quand même elle a donné elle
insiste pour dire ce n'est pas contre
les musulmans et en ce sens elle se
distingue d'Éric Zemmour
si vous avez vu hier dans le monde
également et sorti une tribune des
anciens ministres des droits des femmes
qui ont dit Marine Le Pen n'est pas la
Défenseur des droits des femmes il n'est
pas féministe et je me suis j'ai trouvé
que c'était intéressant de le noter
c'était il y a besoin de le réaffirmer
parce que de la fin c'est une stratégie
de toute l'extrême droite en Europe
c'est à dire qu'il y a attaque
l'Islam ou non de des droits des femmes
au nom des droits des homosexuels au nom
de la
liberté qui serait mise en cause par les
musulmans dans nos en Europe et donc
c'est sur ce terrain là qu'elle essaye
de de forcer la porte et je crois pas
qu'elle est réussie hier soir je pense
que Emmanuel Macron l'a bien bloqué sur
ce terrain-là mais c'était quand même sa
stratégie et donc elle se démarque de
Zemmour et elle continue sa stratégie de
pour faire rentrer ses idées sans les
prendre sans prendre frontalement mais
là elle bloque l'accès à tous les
électeurs potentiels de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon parce que ça c'est vraiment le
point de clivage c'est à dire que quand
on vote Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui a lu
vraiment une stratégie quasiment
clientéliste vis-à-vis vis-à-vis des
musulmans ou des populations immigrées
elle elle est complètement à
contre-courant et donc là c'est pas
possible la passerelle elle est plus
possible sur cette question là c'est
certain c'est certain que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon c'est quand même identifié
avec le débat contre Zemmour au départ
je crois que ça a été quand même un
événement marquant de la campagne de
quand même très très mal perçue dans la
jeunesse pas simplement dans les
banlieues dans le les grandes villes
c'est quelque chose qui ne passe pas
quoi pierre-latrise on a dit globalement
dans ce débat que chacun s'était adressé
à son électorat cette séquence c'est un
peu elle elle place un peu de bémol quoi
elle rend l'analyse un peu plus subtile
parce que Emmanuel Macron il s'adresse
aussi à l'électorat de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon à ce moment-là il rejoue le
fond républicain moi je suis assez
d'accord je pense que c'est pas c'est
quelque chose qui va être difficile à
assumer pour elle parce que vis-à-vis de
lectorat de gauche c'est quand même une
mesure qui paraît très brutale c'est pas
juste une histoire de restriction
d'immigration c'est vraiment là on est
dans quelque chose qui peut paraître
assez brutal et Emmanuel Macron
évidemment mais ça en avant pour dire
voilà moi je encore une fois vous êtes
je suis peut-être pas le président dont
vous rêviez mais en attendant avec moi
il n'y aura pas d'interdiction du voile
il n'y aura pas de restriction et puis
effectivement dans la dans la oui alors
il y a il y a oui alors là c'est vrai
qu'Emmanuel Macron on va en parler après
mais c'est on peut l'évoquer ce passage
là est un aussi un passage un moment
important du débat oui oui parce que là
elle elle a cherché à dire que je suis
la candidate de la Concorde vous avez
divisé les Français et là il lui dit non
vous allez faire la guerre civile si
vous vous allez au bout de cette de
cette mesure recoudre la France c'était
punchline sur punchline il nous reste
deux trois minutes est-ce qu'il y a des
des thèmes qui vous ont manqué est-ce
que parce qu'on a il y a ça a été vaste
ça a duré 2h50 donc on va peut-être pas
souhaiter que ça dure 3h30 la prochaine
fois mais Laetitia cru pas est-ce qu'il
y a des malgré tout des thèmes que que
vous avez regretté de ne pas voir
aborder
certainement beaucoup là aiment bien
tout de suite c'est l'égalité femme
homme parce que c'était un des grands
chantiers même la priorité du
quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron et qu'on
n'y est pas encore enfin je veux dire ça
semble complètement aberrant d'avoir
encore une disparité salariale je sais
pas sur quels critères il faudra un jour
m'expliquer mais voilà je trouve que ça
c'est complètement et et c'est aussi un
positionnement nouveau de Marine Le Pen
qui pendant cette campagne tenter de se
poser en féminisme et alors c'était
vraiment mais alors c'était
révolutionnaire dans la bouche de Marine
Le Pen donc j'aurais bien aimé
l'entendre défendre la cause des femmes
et notamment des familles monoparentales
parce que elle s'est fait aussi comme ça
la défenseuse je sais pas si ça se dit
le défenseur de cette cause et puis
c'est passé alors que ça c'est très
concernant c'est du quotidien voilà
c'est du concret un thème qui vous a
manqué Frédéric potier ou pas d'ailleurs
je crois que beaucoup de sujets étaient
effleurer comme ça et certains ont pas
été approfondis comme ils l'auraient dû
être simplement peut-être les sujets de
territoire de décentralisation c'est un
sujet qui a pas été trop abordé oui
d'ailleurs c'est assez flou parce que
Madame Macron elle dit plusieurs fois
qu'il va un peu changer le système le
gouvernance en disant pour l'éducation
la santé il y aura de grands principes
édités au niveau national et puis
ensuite bon mais on comprend pas bien
comment ça pourrait se mettre en place
c'est pour ça que c'est pas un débat
qu'il aurait fallu avoir mais peut-être
deux trois d'ailleurs peut-être qu'il
faut complètement chambouler le format
là aux États-Unis voilà et peut-être la
question des discriminations aussi qui a
été à peine effleurer alors que je pense
que c'est un sujet extrêmement important
notamment chez les jeunes mais pas
seulement et l'hôpital j'ai oublié ça y
est l'hôpital oui mais pas vraiment
nécessaire de l'hôpital on a toujours
pas compris c'est pas juste augmenter
les salaires parce que c'est il faut
restructurer ripoliner pour reprendre un
mot d'Emmanuel Macron et là pour
l'instant les mesures elles sont vagues
bon et on n'a pas parlé de Gérard Majax
parce qu'on avait décidé de ne pas en
parler merci beaucoup d'avoir participé
à ce à ce débat je rappelle le titre de
votre livre Frédéric potier pierre malin
France la foi démocratique livre publié
aux éditions bouquins et puis Catherine
tricot on va revoir la couverture de la
revue regard Jean-Luc Mélenchon à la Une
la gauche c'est